well this is an interesting question i
mean this question of how predetermined
is
reality you know if you believe in time
travel into the future
it's very hard to believe in that
without believing that the future in
some sense exists now
and if you're a careful thinker
you realize that that raises some real
philosophical problems in other words if
reality is entirely predetermined
then one of the first casualties of a
predetermined universe is the idea of
truth
because
in a predetermined universe you think
what you think because you can't think
anything else
well how can you seek truth without the
possibility of error
you can't i mean it just means you know
i believe what i believe because i can't
help myself you believe what you believe
because you can't help yourself and
there's no way to approach truth uh
without the possibility of error i
it now it's obvious
that much of the world is predetermined
for example we can
i can tell you if we got down to it to
the millisecond
when the sun will rise what time the
sunrise will be
on a given day a century hence
now interestingly chaos theory teaches
us
that if you ask me what time will the
sun rise on january 1st
1 million a.d
this question cannot be answered because
uh chaotic factors make it impossible
even to pre-compute the future orbits of
the planets we don't know where jupiter
will be in a hundred million years
we can
compute out into the future these simple
systems for a few iterations
but not to infinity once it was thought
that you could do this but fractals and
chaos theory and dynamics have now
secured that we don't see as far into
time as we thought
i think the way i understand the
the predetermination thing is
what is predetermined in the future is
not what will happen
but
sort of
the levels of novelty and habit that
will reside in any given moment
but not the facts of the matter that
will secure the truth of that statement
do you understand what i mean here
here's an example that maybe makes it
clear
by looking at the past
we can say with very high confidence
that in the next 12 months
between 6 and 11 people will throw
themselves to their death from the
golden gate bridge
we we will be right
in this statement
but now
those six to 11 people
are they out there today
marked for death and doomed beyond all
possibility of redemption
or has it yet been decided who will
fulfill this probabilistic
prediction i say it isn't
there's nobody out there
marked for death by throwing themselves
off the golden gate bridge
6 7 8 9 10 or 11 people will do this in
the next 12 months but i could be one of
them
or i could not be one of them a way of
thinking of it is that the landscape of
the future is set
but how one will march across it
what path one will take to cross it is
not determined
there has to be a degree of freedom in
the system and indeed the news out of
chaos theory and dynamics is that over
long periods of time the freedom of the
system overwhelms all effort to
calculate it forward and that's why you
can't say where jupiter will be in its
orbital path 100 million years
in the future
[Music]
[Music]
you